hello and welcome to this video Matty
2000 is the opponent so comes gambit
probably yep let's go for the slow Slav
playing this line that's a bit out of
fashion but not so bad yeah it looks a
bit strange to play for an exchange kind
of position exchanges laughs can appear
with the bishop out an f5 and whites
Bush won't see one but White has a
chance to see em to put Bishop d2 and be
foreign to try to trade that a dark
square vision and in some cases black is
also one losing some time here why is
that even possible okay there's a
related line somewhat similar lines
maybe the word I'm looking for whoa so
okay I'm not okay i will take anyway
something might as well do it do it
immediately so what about this maybe
Bishop b5 is the difference then I'm
threatening Queen c6 now rook be eight
Queens is six
there is a somewhat similar line with
knight on c3 and then mmm okay i might
play b5 hear that that's possible Bishop
c6 you cannot play I think it should be
excellent for white rupee five many okay
check
yeah you're not going to play Queen d7
here
yeah white gets ton ton of material for
the tyrrhenian I mean ton of material i
get a pawn the power-on be seven and
three minor pieces plus a very good
position I think
yeah I can take the rook as well
no reason not to i think queen bee six
maybe but still i can take you five
queen 85 this Knight c3 chats Quincy 727
wasn't it was that was a problem
actually who 27 equally valid
I should have given the check I really
should have came the check why I'm if I
didn't I do that thats it's very silly
now I have to worry about the bishop him
shoot very bad
just Bishop c6 before and it's over and
now this is not so easy at all
I would a terrible game why did lab
table ship c6 check it was so much
better let's just try to clarify the
situation here maybe for let's not a bad
night
takes it that's a big pin so let's see
can we do something here with the back
wank which is sound also nice to get in
let's do this first
hmm
that's Jim don't have perfect
coordination here really don't time
warning check
put the night on f5 here after king of
88 otherwise e6 I'm not sure that this
is even good to be honest oh it's
covering covering this it's pretty awful
playing this very very badly the whole
game is a big is absolutely badly played
so we're need to try to coordinate my
position somehow now check pretty awful
sorry for order for all the moaning yeah
it just is pretty awful you have a very
good position out of the opening and
play it so badly check that at you have
to deal with this position here check
check check check check I'm sure that
I'm losing here channel check check and
I mean I'm losing on time but position
like foreheads yeah it was well deserved
I have prayed like a complete idiot I
mean it was it was an utterly winning
position around tea and I started to
play complete nonsense so here okay it
wasn't winning okay let's start it was
winning and the way it was whatever it
was it was played let's say this this
whole thing is so not working due to
this is this I know Quincy search but
you didn't play Queen 85 does this just
hence me the game I just have to play
this check sure and the game is over
yeah King the eight you should be too
and this is a very simple wind I just
coordinate the pieces and win I've got
two pieces and the rook against the
Queen and he's got a bad King position
so it's very simple and now things are
not easy at all I should have probably
taken immediately but this is still of
course just winning yeah just buy
material and that i didn't manage that
it's just just terrible so f form
probably damn i completely played this
all wrong letting come we have seven and
things like that this is something that
he never should have got now black is
much easier to play
I'm not sure maybe them check check hold
a lot of harm or clear up check check
the shadow check check yeah I'm not 100%
sure that this is actually actually a
win from like could be a fortress
impossible possible but I deservedly
lost because i played this like a
complete [ __ ] and yeah very bad okay
anyway thanks for watching